over to Israel now where protesters are
holding a day of national resistance in
opposition to judicial changes proposed
by the government this comes after the
knesset passed the first reading of a
controversial Bill to limit the Supreme
Court's Powers the biggest protests are
expected in the evening on Tuesday in
Jerusalem and Tel Aviv
Muhammad jamshun joins us live from West
Jerusalem with much more on this and
Mohammed we've been talking about this
for some time now after many months many
weeks of protests the pressure clearly
remains firmly on the Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
that's right and you've already today
you've had thousands of people dozens of
rallies in cities across central Israel
they include uh Tel Aviv Rana Rama's
gone
um and the crowd seem to only be getting
better bigger we are expecting that
within a couple of hours from now there
will be a protest in West Jerusalem
outside of the Supreme Court which is
really at the heart of all this
controversy because the people that have
been coming out to protest are
protesting because this judicial
overhaul package has been proposed by
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
his far-right Coalition Partners would
significantly limit the power of the
Supreme Court and the Judiciary as a
whole now today the fact of the matter
is that at least 19 people have been
arrested already that's according to the
Israeli police they say they were
arrested for public disorder you've had
highways that were blocked you've had
demonstrators show up on Bridges outside
of train stations uh and really what
this goes to show is that the
demonstrators are continued to be
mobilized despite the heat it's very hot
here today despite all the obstacles in
their way they say they are going to
continue to come out to continue to try
to put pressure on prime minister
Netanyahu on members of his far-right
coalition to get them to stop trying to
advance this proposal I'm talking about
advancing The Proposal what next for
this controversial build now that it's
past the first reading in the knesset
so this is one particular bill that's
part of the larger proposal the package
of laws has been proposed by the Prime
Minister this one bill passed its first
reading this past Monday and after that
passage that first vote in the knesset
needs to pass three votes in the knesset
before it would be enacted into law
after that first passage last Monday you
had thousands of people come out on the
streets on Tuesday that was called a day
of disruption today it's called a day of
resistance and what's expected now is
that perhaps by Monday you would have uh
the final reading at some point of this
of this bill
um but the demonstrators say they are
committed to trying to ensure that the
Prime Minister will not go ahead now the
Prime Minister for his part has said
repeatedly that he is going to go ahead
that he does want to push this through
this one particular bill then he's going
to take a step back then he is going to
try to come to some sort of a compromise
with the opposition parties when it
comes to the broader package of laws
that have been proposed earlier this
year eve okay muhammadoon in West
Jerusalem many thanks for that